hello it's beebadooby and today i'm with
buzzfeed to revisit the past by making a
playlist of my favorite songs from
secondary school years
if you want to listen along click the
link in the description box to access my
playlist
i was born in iloilo philippines and
then i moved to london when i was
three secondary school was about
three or two years ago yeah i was 17.
during secondary school i was living in
camden
and my school was in hammersmith so it
was like
an hour and a half trek i went to an
all-girl catholic school
i didn't really fit in i had no idea
that i was going to do music at one
point i really wanted to be a doctor and
then i got
a u in science which means like
ungradable i just felt quite alienated
at times and then i thankfully met an
amazing group of friends that
accepted me with who i was and and we
all listened to the same music
and secondary school was great because
of them my first song choice is
sticks and stones by jamie t i remember
it
always being played every time my
friends and i would do this this is so
messed up but we would do these like
all-nighters like on the weekends and
this is like
we'd stay out all night and just get
super worked up
um and this would always get played
during the end of the night
and just the whole chorus the melody of
that whole chorus
is like amazing like it just stays in
your head and it's like
it's a very kind of sing-along type of
song and
good days also kind of unhealthy days
but
really good days the next song is called
just like henry
by dressy bessie i actually discovered
this song
when watching a movie called by my
cheerleader which has the most amazing
soundtrack and it's like an all-female
soundtrack which is so badass it's sick
i guess it was just like a really fun
girly dancy song
and i just have this massive thing about
dancing in my bedroom loads and i
remember being
in school and my friends every time one
of us would have like
we'd have like a free house we'd go over
and just play music
really loud and dance like stupid we
all couldn't dance but that song
together with the but i'm a cheerleader
soundtrack really influenced
my most recent debut album fake flowers
and it was just
i wanted to create an album for people
to dance to in their bedrooms because i
think that's just like
something that is really good for your
mental health essentially like
i can't dance but i would spend hours
with my headphones on and just dancing
in front of my mirror
looking like a maniac every time i'm sad
it always
makes me feel better my next song choice
is velocity girl by snow patrol
it kind of reminds me of the time when i
got like a boyfriend and
i was getting into alternative music
i'd always play the song sounds super
cringe but it just reminds me
of the times where i'd hang out with him
during those days
the one thing that sticks out for me is
the chord progression
i remember when i was doing the space
cadet the ep
before um fake flowers i remember
listening to this song religiously right
and
being like to my producer and we need to
do this song like i
wish i had written this song like it's
one of those songs where i was like
damn not copy it but just you know what
i mean
this next one is called homecoming by
the teenagers
my friend matty showed me this song i
remember listening to it through and
through it's
so funny it's like a type of song i
wouldn't
necessarily play to my parents because
the lyrics are just so odd
but it's so incredibly funny i guess it
just sounds like it's
from like a coming of age film or
something i'm surprised it's not in a
soundtrack yet
it just has that atmosphere it has that
vibe you know that i'm bitten
ratatouille
the critic eats the pasta bowl and he
like takes him back to his childhood
that's what happened when i listened to
that song it was like
this next one's called paraslide by
mineral
i don't know it just like gives off that
mood of just kind of not wanting to
get up in the morning but still having
to do what you don't want to do
and it's i don't know it just like every
time i listen to it it reminds me of
school days
and it inspiring a lot of the next ep
that i'm releasing after fake it flowers
this next one's called trouble sleeping
by karine bailey ray
i love korean bailey rae that whole
record
is insane like she's incredible trouble
sleeping
is one of my favorite songs this is very
early days
during secondary school and i was
listening to a lot of her and like norah
jones
there was this garden in the middle of
my school my school literally looked
like hogwarts but then i got kicked out
so that was kind of sad but
yeah my school looked like hogwarts and
they had this amazing
garth in the middle and a massive like
mary statue and every time i listen to
that song reminds me
of how pretty the garth looked why i got
kicked out
oh god i guess a multiple of reasons and
they later found out that what they did
was quite dodgy and they asked
me to come back it was weird because
they kicked out the girls that were
slightly misbehaved and were also doing
quite bad in school
i had a habit of um ditching quite a lot
and my friends and i
used to smoke a lot in the toilets and
at first they thought they were like
they were okay with it they like made
jokes about something oh having
quick ziggy in the toilets are we i'm
like yeah and they were all like super
chill about it
and i feel like you just kept building
and building and they're just like yep
get out
and they booted me out of school and it
was like at such like a
awkward time because all like the um
application forms for
new schools were already like closed so
we had no school to go to
after getting kicked out but i
thankfully found a school that accepted
me this next one
is called vapor trail by ride this is a
funny one i remember
having this song on my playlist and not
realizing the band and how
actually amazing they were and i
remember like going to the library
being really good and actually revising
and doing so many notes
and being really confident for the exam
and getting all my results back
and it being completely trashed like it
was actually embarrassing i was like i
tried my hardest not to be rude but i
kind of blame it
on ride i feel like their music is so
good
i felt like i was revising but in
reality i was actually just listening to
the music
this next one is contra tempo by
lollypoona
this song i listened to a lot and tour
specifically during the really dark
times of tour
and it always took me back to the really
dark times
in secondary school not that the lyrics
kind of relate to everything i was going
through but there was something about
the melody and something about you know
there's a girl talking throughout the
whole song and it's like
quite atmospheric and it just kind of
takes me back to kind of like a dark
place
but it's really haunting i think that's
the best way to describe it it kind of
like you just get like entranced by it
and get entranced by her voice
and my last choice is deuce by the sugar
cubes
i chose this one because honestly like i
love bjork and she is such a queen and
the sugar cubes
is her old band before she became bjork
i think it just shows like a really fun
kind of innocent side like it's super
amazing and fun and yeah just like
dressy bessie the song
on this playlist it does make me dance a
lot and it does make me
think back to the times when i was with
my friends and he starts a lot bjork is
an amazing artist and i look up to her a
lot by just how much she's
always thinking ahead like she's always
changing she's always thinking about the
future and thinking about what she can
do next
this song specifically i guess like has
influenced me to make
a record to kind of make girls feel
like how i feel when i listen to those
songs that's my ultimate playlist from
my secondary school years let me know
what you think of my choices in the
comments
my new album fake flowers is out if you
want to go and listen to it
you